I have for you the worst example of
media bias I have seen in recent memory
president Trump signs an executive order
that may or may not in family separation
at the border and president Trump
rallies in Minnesota I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
so in case you missed the news this
August I am taking the Ben Shapiro show
live to audiences in Dallas and Phoenix
you'll be able to see me in person and
join in an audience at Q & A tickets are
going really fast they're almost sold
out in Dallas and they're nearing sold
out in Phoenix go to daily wired.com
slash events to get your seats and
additional info it's gonna be a blast
and I really look forward to seeing I'll
you they're all VIP tickets were already
sold out if you're subscriber you get
first crack at those but we still have a
few seats left in Dallas in Phoenix so
please if you're in those cities or you
want to travel to those cities for the
events I think they're gonna be a blast
and I look forward to seeing you there
all right I'm gonna get to the news in
just a second first I want to talk to
you about why you should have some of
your money in precious metals so if you
look at the trade situation right now
President Trump obviously wants to raise
tariffs on countries like China China is
raising tariffs on the United States in
response and you could easily see a
trade war well this is going to have
some pretty significant ramifications
for the currency considering that China
actually could retaliate against the
United States by selling off American
bonds for example well what that really
means is that you ought to have at least
some of your assets in a hard asset like
gold where you should have some of your
assets not all right you should have a
lot of your assets in stocks and bonds
great I have a lot of that stuff in
stocks and bonds too but you should have
some of your assets and precious metals
because my savings plan in every savings
plan should have something that is not
subject to the uncertainty and
instability of inflation or government
manipulation the company I trust with
precious metal purchases Birch gold
group Birch gold sells physical precious
metals for your own possession they will
ship metal directly to your front door
and right now thanks to a little-known
IRS tax law you can even move your IRA
or eligible 401k into an IRA backed by
physical gold and silver it's perfect
for people who want to ensure that their
hard-earned retirement savings are
protected from future geopolitical
uncertainty and there's a reason they
have so many five-star reviews and
there's such a long-standing track
record of continued success contact
Birch gold group right now get a free
information kit on physical precious
metals it's a comprehensive 16 page kit
showing you why and how you should
invest in physical precious metals and
then once you've got all your questions
answered and you've asked all your
questions go to birchgold.com slash bend
that is birchgold.com slash been for
that free information kit and to invest
birchgold.com slash pen use the slash
pen so they know that we say all right
so we have heard non-stop over the last
two weeks that President Trump is Hitler
right President Trump is a Nazi and the
reason President Trump is a Nazi is
because of his policy of separating
children from their parents at the
border when people enter
in the United States not at ports of
entry when they enter across the border
in Arizona for example or Texas and
they're picked up by ice then they are
immediately criminally prosecuted and
that means that by law their kids have
to be separated from them and this means
that Trump is evil-eye Trump is totally
evil now you might ask yourself did this
policy begin with Trump and as had been
saying for well on two weeks now no this
policy did not begin with Trump this
policy began with Barack Obama whose
policy in 2014-2015 was that he would
arrest entire families and keep the kids
unified with the parents and as I had
said also that and there was a 2016
ruling Ninth Circuit Court of Appeals
that says you're not allowed to do that
anymore you have to release the kids
that's what leads to the parental
separation I have also been saying that
if Trump back down on this that if Trump
said we're gonna reunify the families
but keep them in custody immediately
there would be a bunch of Democrats who
signaled that this was unacceptable as
well so separating families was like the
Nazis and keeping families together in
custody is also like the Nazis the only
solution left of course is to release
everybody into the general population
and that's exactly what Democrats have
been pushing for well one of the things
that is truly maddening about this
entire situation is the lack of
intellectual honesty on virtually all
sides on it but particularly from the
left Tammy Baldwin is a senator from
from I believe Wisconsin is the correct
and in Tammy Baldwin was on CNN
yesterday and she specifically asked
about about whether she felt the same
way when young migrant children were
being imprisoned by Barack Obama Brooke
Baldwin actually asked her a solid
question on CNN so good for Brooke
Baldwin
watch Tammy Baldwin struggled to come up
with an answer as to why she wasn't
angry when Barack Obama was imprisoning
children did you raise your voice under
the Obama administration you know in
numbers of cases usually I remember a
constituent who was in detention at the
border arguably very inappropriately and
we
you know we raised our voice in that
instance and many others but that's
we've got to do this now in unison it's
not enough to do it case-by-case or
senator or a House member by house
member we've got to resolve to fix this
issue okay so not to know okay that's a
no I didn't care what Obama was
president yes I do care when when Donald
Trump is president the best evidence
that the media seriously don't care
about this issue until Trump is
president comes today courtesy of The
Associated Press so there's a story from
The Associated Press here's the title
young immigrants detained in Virginia
censor allege abuse now you and imagine
just from reading that title that the
allegations of abuse are taking place
because of stuff that is happening today
right allegations of abuse that are
happening today in the Shenandoah Valley
juvenile center then it's all about
trumped now this story mentions Donald
Trump seven separate times in the course
of this very long story from The
Associated Press it mentions Barack
Obama zero times in this very long story
about abuses at detention centers of
illegal immigrant miners and now there's
only one problem all of the abuse is
alleged in the story happened under
Barack Obama's watch all of them
happened in 2015 2016 that is buried in
paragraph 19 of this story paragraph 19
so paragraph 19 they finally mentioned
oh by the way all these illegal
immigrant miners were abused and
allegedly abused they're abused under
Obama they mentioned that in paragraph
19 and they mentioned Donald Trump seven
times in the mentioned Barack Obama by
name zero times and then you wonder why
when Donald Trump goes to his rallies
and he shouts about fake news and people
cheer and chant fake news you wonder why
people take Donald Trump seriously when
he says fake news because you bury the
lead and then you don't report that
Obama had anything to do with it and how
bad were these abuses the answer is
pretty damn bad here's the Associated
Press immigrant children as young as 14
housed at a juvenile detention center in
Virginia say they were beaten well
handcuffed and locked up for long
periods in solitary confinement left
nude and shivering and concrete cells
the abuse claims against the Shenandoah
Valley juvenile Center near Stanton
Virginia are detailed in federal court
filings that include a half-dozen sworn
statements from Latino G teens jailed
there for months or years multiple
detainees say the guards stripped them
of their clothes and strapped them to
chairs with bags placed over their heads
whenever they used to restrain me and
put me in the chair they would handcuff
me said a Honduran immigrant who was
sent to the facility when he was 15
strapped me down all the way from your
feet all the way to your chest you
couldn't really move
total control over you they'll split a
bag over your head it has little holes
you can see through but you feel
suffocated with the bag on in addition
to the children's first hand translated
accounts in court filings a former child
development specialist who worked inside
the facility independently told the AP
this week she saw kids there with
bruises and broken bones they blamed on
guards she spoke on condition of
anonymity because she was not authorised
to publicly discuss the children's cases
now normally when I lead a story and
when I write a story I usually say on
Wednesday or in 2015 the date is the
first thing you say because it's sort of
matters to the story you don't get any
dates here until paragraph nineteen
first you get this paragraph many of the
children were sent there after US
immigration authorities accused them of
belonging to violent gangs including
ms-13 President Donald Trump has
repeatedly cited gang activity as
justification for his crackdown on
illegal immigration so that sounds like
Donald Trump has been saying everybody's
ms-13 so Isis out they're arresting a
bunch of innocent kids throwing them in
prison and torturing them because they
say they're ms-13 right that's what you
would get from that ap story and the AAP
continues like this right Trump said
Wednesday that our Border Patrol agents
and our ice agents have done one great
job cracking down on ms-13 measures an
ms-13 gang members we're throwing them
out by the thousands he said but a top
manager at the shenandoah Center said
during a recent congressional hearing
that the children did not appear to be
gang members and were suffering from
mental health issues resulting from
trauma that happened in their home
country's problems the detention
facility is ill-equipped to treat and
then this is the best part okay so
finally this is now in let's see
paragraph 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 paragraph 10
ok paragraph 10 we finally get to a
point here most children held in the
Shannons own facility where the focus of
the abuse lawsuit were caught crossing
the border illegally alone they were not
the children who have been separated
from their families under the trump
administration's recent policy and are
now in the government's care okay so in
other words this has nothing to do with
the current issues that are being
debated about family separation and then
all the way down in paragraph 19 all the
way down in paragraph 19 we get this the
complaint filed by the nonprofit
Washington lawyers Committee for civil
rights and urban affairs recounts the
story of an unnamed 17 year old Mexican
citizen apprehended at the southern
border the team fled an abusive father
and violence fueled by drug cartels to
seek asylum in the United States in 2015
let me recall
when was the election of 2016 oh that's
right it was after 2015 it turns out
turns out 2016 after 2015 after stops at
facilities in Texas in New York he was
transferred to Shenandoah in April 2016
but wait Donald Trump wasn't president
then right if I recall he was even the
nominee for the Republicans at that
point in April 2016 but you don't find
that out until paragraph 20 of a 1000
word article and this article is not
1000 words an article probably 3,000
words okay I love this the lawyers for
Shannon's all responded with court
filings denying all wrongdoing
information contained in a separate 2016
lawsuit appears to support some of the
information contained in the recent
abuse complaints wait a second there was
a separate 2016 lawsuit meaning was
publicly available in 2016 where is it
now yeah it's 2018 what happened in the
intervening two years did somebody was
there a presidential change that's right
Donald Trump became president and only
then to the media start reporting on
lawsuits alleging horrible abuses
happening under Barack Obama
I remember Obama's administration was
scandal-free Barack Obama says so and
that means that it's true we also know
that there was an ACLU report in 2015
talking about detainee abuse is between
2009 and 2014 did you ever hear about
that of course he didn't hear about that
cuz nobody cared
he's Barack Obama was president and
Barack Obama was the bringer of light
Barack Obama loved immigrants how do we
know we know because he said so and the
media said so here's the story another
story like this was from the Drudge
Report the tragic case of Roberto
Aguilar Batista 38 whose family sued
Barack Obama and multiple federal
agencies after Batista died from
complications of diabetes while being
held in one of the administration's
ill-equipped detention centers in a
report published August 29 2014 CBS to
Los Angeles says quote at a news
conference Friday attended by CBS 2's
Amy Johnson Nancy Munna said her husband
had type 2 diabetes and his care was
neglected he was held at the
Metropolitan Detention Center among
other places last March 2014 Roberto
Aguilar Bautista died from complications
of diabetes at the Dalbey Correctional
Facility in other words there were lots
and lots and lots of detainee abuses
cocaine it was considered a detainee
abuse to keep children together with
their parents and yet the media are only
interested in a crime Rachel Maddow is
crying openly on-air about the
separation of children from parents now
in a second I'm going to show you why
the Trump administration's response to
this has been so foolish because the
reality is Trump sure is stuck to his
guns here
listen we have a zero-tolerance policy
you cross the border getting arrested
and it is not up to me to change the law
I cannot unilaterally change the law the
job of the executive branch is to
execute the law the 9th Circuit Court of
Appeals has already ruled that a
settlement between the Clinton
administration government 1997 and
illegal immigrants in 1997 the Florida
settlement 9th Circuit Court of Appeals
rules that settlement means I cannot
keep children together with parents but
I am NOT going to release everybody into
the interior of the country Trump should
have maintained that line because that
is the correct legal line instead
President Trump decided that he was
going to announce an executive order
under pressure that's because the
polling numbers were really not good on
this stuff and the media attention on it
obviously has been incredibly biased but
here was president Trump yesterday
announcing that that he was going to
sign an executive order and then we'll
go through the text of the executive
order in just a second we want to keep
families together it's very important
I'll be signing something in a little
while that's going to do that and the
people in this room want to do that and
they're working on various pieces of
legislation to get it done but I thought
be doing something that's somewhat
preemptive but ultimately will be
matched by the legislation I'm sure ok
so he says that he's gonna sign an
executive agreement now we had the
executive order now I have the text of
the executive order and all I can say is
that it's either really stupid or it is
really clever one of the two and I'll
explain what I mean by that in just a
second first I want to say thanks to our
sponsors over at Boleyn branch so ok I
am not good at sleeping as I have said
many many times on this show but one of
the things that allows me to sleep like
a baby when I'm in my own house is my
bowl and branch eat so Boleyn branch
eats are just the best they really are
terrific you don't think about the
sheets that are on your bed you're
probably still sleeping on the sheets
that your parents gave you when you're
13 okay but if you don't want those
sheets if you want something that's
actually really nice Bowl and branch
sheets will do it for you there are
three ex presidents and Bill Clinton's
lovers who sleep on these sheets they
are just incredible there they don't
worry about the thread count they are
made of organic cotton okay thread count
doesn't mean anything by the way I
didn't even know that I always thought
one of these guys who drives past the
gas station like we have a five thousand
thread count sheet over here and then
you open it up in its natural plastic
tarp well it's not the thread count that
matters so much it's the actual quality
of the sheet and these are made of pure
organic cotton which means that they get
softer with each washer they are just
horrific we actually threw out all of
our sheets after we started working with
branch and got all brand-new sheets for
us for our kids they're really terrific
if you got these kinds of sheets at the
store it would cost you upward of a
thousand bucks but Poland brand sheets
are only a couple of hundred dollars
right now shipping is free you can try
them for 30 nights as well so if you
don't like them they don't have to pay
for him right mean to get you started
right now my listeners get 50 bucks off
your first set of sheets at at ball and
branch comm promo code Ben that's Bo LL
and branch comm promo code Ben 50 bucks
off your first set of sheets bull and
branch comm promo club and there's a
reason we love our Bolin branch eats
they are awesome Bo ll and branch comm
promo code men if you don't love them
you send them back for a refund because
you can try them for 30 days and
shipping is free so go check them out
right now you have nothing to lose
Boleyn branch common promo club and
you're definitely going to want to keep
them you're not gonna want to shift them
and ship them back okay so let's go
through president Trump's executive
order as I have said the Trump
administration does not have the legal
ability to keep children together with
their parents in detention that is a
Ninth Circuit Court of Appeals ruling
based on the Obama administration's
policy of keeping children together with
parents in detention at the time this
was considered inhumane
I had folks on the Left suggested that
it was inhumane to keep children in
detention with their parents now they're
suggesting it is inhumane to separate
children from their parents in detention
so here is what Trump actually put in
the executive order the executive order
is one of two things just as a
preliminary note either it reinstates
catch and release
meaning that all of these parents have
to be released into the general
population or it does nothing but those
are the only two choices this doesn't
actually say that kids can now be kept
with their parents in facilities instead
what it basically says is to the fullest
extent of law parents should be kept
together with their kids it's kind of
meaningless okay so here's what it says
it says and by the authority vested in
me as president of the United States and
by the Constitution's of the and by the
laws of the United States of America
including the Immigration and
Nationality Act it is hereby ordered as
follows it is the policy of this
administration to rigorously rigorously
enforce our immigration laws under our
laws the only legal way for an alien to
enter this country is it is in a
designated port of entry at an
appropriate time
when an alien enters or attempts to
enter the country anywhere else that
alien has committed at least the crime
of improper entry and is subject to a
fine or imprisonment under Section 1325
a of title 8 United States Code this
administration will initiate proceedings
to enforce this and other criminal
provisions of the ia until and unless
Congress directs otherwise it is also
the policy of this administration to
maintain family
including by detaining alien families
together where appropriate and
consistent with law and available
resources it is unfortunate that
Congress's failure to act and corers
have put the administration in the
position of separating alien families to
effectively enforce the law okay so so
far this has not said anything so far
this is just reinstated the the Trump
administration's policy which is we're
going to arrest everybody and we'd like
to keep the families together but we
can't legally speaking okay then they
get into the actual operative portion of
this okay temporary detention policy for
families entering the country illegally
the Secretary of Homeland Security shall
to the extent permitted by law and
subject to the availability of
appropriations maintain custody of alien
families during the pendency of any
criminally improper entry or immigration
proceedings involving their members the
Secretary shall not however detain an
alien family together when there is a
concern that detention of an alien
family with the child's alien parent
would pose a risk to the child's welfare
the Secretary of Defense shall take all
legally available means to provide for
the secretary any existing facilities
available for housing or carat of alien
families now as you'll note the
Secretary of Homeland Security shall to
the extent permitted by law the law does
not permit them to keep these kids
together with their parents in the
facilities that means that they're
either going to have to release the
parents or they don't have to separate
the parents so they're nothing changed
or everything changed okay this
executive order doesn't actually do much
nonetheless we're gonna talk about the
media response to it because the media
response to it is so bifurcated it's so
crazy so let's talk a little bit about
about the media response to this
actually you know first let me point
something out here's a chart on catch
and release okay so catch and release is
the policy that pre-existed Trump where
instead of arresting everybody across
the border illegally instead they would
just arrest a bunch of people and then
they would release them into the society
and then they would hope that they
showed back up in court for their day in
court well in absentia rates for
released aliens initial case completions
fiscal year 2016 only 39% of people in
2016 who were arrested and then released
39% of them never showed up again so
nearly 40% for intent frankly I'm
shocked that that it's only four in said
I'm shocked it's not seven in ten that's
a huge number of people that means that
there were there were nine thousand
seven hundred and twenty-two in absentia
orders that were declared in 2016 so
there were almost 10,000 people who went
missing basically in 2016 alone after
they were arrested and then released
into
that's the reason why Trump wants to
keep them in custody because the idea is
if you release them they're just going
to run away which is of course perfectly
right well president Trump signs this
executive order and as I say legally
speaking because he cannot keep the
families together he has two choices he
can separate the families or he can
release the entire family so either the
executive order reinstate
catch-and-release or the executive order
does nothing and now my inclination is
gonna be the executive order does a lot
of nothing but it looks as that here's
the problem with what Trump just did
Trump is maintained for two weeks that
he can't actually do anything by
executive order and then he actually
didn't do much by this executive order
the executive order doesn't actually do
anything so why did he do it and the
answer is he didn't like the headline a
president Trump has a bad habit of he
gets himself into hot water and then all
of the people around him stand up and
defend what he's done right they defend
at least the policy they say this is
legally defensible
and then President Trump doesn't like
the blowback and then he mountain
undercuts his own side by going and
saying you know I'm gonna sign an
executive order and fix all of this
and well you can't sign this guy this
executive or doesn't do anything right
it is ineffective but it does hand a
headline to the left which is Trump
folded Trump cave so Stephen Colbert
last night on his execrable show he said
that president from folded by issuing
this executive order make no mistake
Trump folded he folded like an origami
Trump casino this is the first time I
have seen president Trump fold write
this he's never done this before he
folded for the first time so how did we
get here okay and then he talks about we
got here through public pressure we got
here because you spoke out right Trump
folded like a house of cheap cards right
that's what he did here's the problem
the same media that is saying that he
folded so that you mean problem over
right I mean if he folded then the
problem is over except for that was
never the agenda the actual agenda of
the left is full release of anyone
coming across the border there's a
feeling on the left that ice itself is
inappropriate that there is something
deeply wrong with even arresting people
at the border so Samantha be the least
funny person in America she won that
title a couple of weeks ago outright
might've been in a running gun battle
with Trevor Noah and Amy Schumer and
Lena Dunham but she actually took the
cake after her rant against Ivanka Trump
she actually took the gold medal
she ran away like like Secretariat was
pretty amazing well now she comes
forward she says listen Trump retreats
on separating families and then he signs
in order to detain them together but for
Samantha B this is not enough why
because she wants them all released into
general society that's the whole point
yay no more baby internment camps just
regular internment camps cool that's
what we call a win in 2018 to be clear I
am happy that at least these kids are
theoretically gonna stay with their
parents but mommy and me jails are not a
solution they're not new and they're
also not legal
man is she unfunny my goodness I mean
being her audience most people be like
being in a comedy internment camp my
goodness that's just she's the worst Wow
but the point that she's making is the
point the Democrats were always going to
make and I have been saying this for
weeks for weeks for weeks for weeks
not say I told you so but I period told
period you period so I told you so Ike I
told you that as soon as Trump said he's
willing to hold the families together
Democrats were immediately going to
claim that something egregious had gone
on something egregious was now going on
we were back to the policy there obama
embraced but that was bad enough all we
want is full release oh yeah Bernie
Sanders saying that's who here's Bernie
Sanders saying that president Trump's
executive order it did not go far enough
it did not include putting funding for
me and my friends and also I will not
share my pudding with actual illegal
immigrants but they will rant about it
until I get my pudding from one of my
aides
so please talk Anderson Cooper to Bernie
Sanders and then later Bernie Sanders
will eat his pudding the idea of tearing
little children from the arms of their
parents putting them into detention
cages and then making a big deal about
an executive order which may do
absolutely nothing there was a crisis
that he created and attempted to address
today but he didn't go anywhere near far
enough okay the only way the Democrats
are gonna feel that President Trump went
far enough is if he does he on mass
release rise that he gets an on mass
release of all of these people and that
of course is the whole point here right
that's what the media is pushing for as
well as for the media are pushing for
here was Time magazine's new cover Time
magazine has a brand new cover out and
what exactly is their cover well it's
this obnoxious thing so it's it's a
cover of a crying child but supposedly
being separate from the parents staring
up at President Trump who is grinning
down at the kid right because and then
it says welcome to America
Time magazine right I don't remember
this sort of cover with Barack Obama and
his giant camp full of children who are
wrapped in aluminum foil but I am seeing
this
cover the whole point here is that no
matter what from does he loses according
to the media so if that's the case why
not just enforce the law and then put it
back on Congress well in just a second
I'm going to explain to you why it is
that the Democrats are pushing all of
this and what they think that the policy
actually should be but first I want to
say thanks to our sponsors are over at
Tommy John so let's let's talk a little
bit let's talk a little bit about your
underwear I know you feel like any
inappropriate well too bad because let's
be real your underwear are deeply
uncomfortable not only are they
uncomfortable they roll and they stick
and they give you wedgies and all the
rest of it well that is why Tommy John's
lightweight breathable fabrics and
wedgie-proof designs keep you cool and
comfortable all summer long Tommy John
is the most incredible fit you've ever
experienced or it's on them they have a
best pair you will ever wear or it's
free guarantee and you're never going to
have to worry again about being in
uncomfortable sticky heat because of
your underwear instead you've got these
fantastic underwear from Tommy John
they've revolutionary clothes okay they
combine the latest in fabric technology
with patented wedgie proof designs for a
fit so perfect it's almost like wearing
nothing at all and you'll never have to
worry about swamp-like conditions down
below down south because Tommy John's
moisture wicking fabrics pull
perspiration right off your body they're
cool cotton fabrics rise four to five
times faster and keeps you 2 to 3 times
cooler than traditional Cotton's so
that's pretty awesome and it's gonna be
a hot summer so make sure that you get
Tommy John and as I say all Tommy John
underwear is back but their best pair
you'll ever wear or it's free guarantee
I wear Tommy John's all the time it
protects me from wedgies that's my
that's my chief concern ever since high
school and so go to Tommy John comm
slash Shapiro for 20% off your first
order that's Tommy John comm slash
apparel for 20% off again Tommy John
comm slash appear you get 20% off and
you're getting the best underwear on the
planet so go to tommy chong kham slash
spray let them know he's saying get 20%
off ok so this has become very obvious
the Democrats never cared about the
policy of separation they never cared
about it this was all a ruse the
Democrats were fully concerned only and
explicitly with destroying Donald Trump
how do we know this number 1 Chuck
Schumer refused the opportunity to put a
legislative fix on this boo-boo
I Ted Cruz wanted a legislative fix
Chuck Schumer said no we're gonna put
Trump's feet to the fire instead you
cannot simultaneously argue that the
policy is not yes and then turn down the
opportunity to change the policy that's
not how this works
hello Stewie no well now Trump has
supposedly changed the policy now as I
explained I don't think the policy
actually changed League
speaking but supposedly Trump changed
the policy and how do Democrats respond
they respond by saying well good for
president Trump's about time that we
changed this or you know we pressured
Trump into this good for us we finally
did it we've won a big victory that is
not how they responded how did they
respond well they responded by saying we
need more release everyone hears Kamala
Harris his tweets Oh Kamala Harris my
awful awful senator from the state of
California she tweeted out this
executive order doesn't fix the crisis
indefinitely detaining children with
their families and camps is inhumane and
will not make us safe so again if you
separate the kids from the families
that's inhumane but if you keep the kids
with the parents that's also inhumane so
the only solution left by process of
elimination is to release everyone which
of course is the entire goal and by the
way justifies everything Trump has been
saying about Democrats don't like
borders the Democrats just want illegal
immigrants released into the general
population that that actually is the
priority if that's not their priority
they need to propose a policy solution
that allows us to arrest illegal
immigrants who come in here with kids
otherwise they're not providing us a
policy solution they just want people
released generally and then Eric's wall
well is another Congress person another
Democrat Congress person he comes for he
says this Trump executive orders gonna
lead to internment camps Democrat from
California this could lead to Family
internment camps wolf and that is what
we do not want to see and the way to
avoid that is to still follow that
Flores decision which is a humane
decision that does not want people in
camps like this indefinitely
okay this is my favorite part okay so my
favorite part of this is that that was
the policy okay the new Trump policy
keeping these kids together with their
parents that was the Trump policy the
stated Trump policy up in the the Obama
policy the government policy up till
2015-2016 hey Obama implemented that
policy so luis Gutierrez who is a
radical leftist friend from Illinois he
was asked about this where he said well
hold honestly hold up a second you know
you're ripping on Trump now saying that
he's gonna keep the families together
that's what Obama did why didn't you
complain about Obama on any of this
here's Louise Gutierrez answering that
question we did challenge Obama but you
know what Obama had a heart he had a
soul he had a heart he had a center he
had convictions and we could speak to
those okay so in other words we
challenged him but really we massaged
his asked really what our challenge was
really mostly us getting
the massage oils and just really going
to work on President Obama that's it
that's basically how we challenged him
because he had a heart he had a soul I
looked into his eyes and it was romantic
we had that long lingering awkward
moment before we kissed I mean it look
really that was the way that you
challenged Barack Obama whose policy was
exactly the same as the current
reinstated policy of Donald Trump the
only difference between Trump's policy
and Obama's policy is the Trump is doing
it more often that is literally the only
difference the only difference that
Trump is actually attempting to strictly
enforce border crossings he's using
criminal court instead of civil
convictions in order to enforce the
border and Obama did that but not as
much that's the only difference and yet
we are told that Obama had a heart
janna so how do we know he had a heart
you got a soul because he had a DUI
isn't it that's the real answer we had
to die by his name and that means that
he had a heart and he had a soul by the
way the Democrats proposed legislation
on border separation with let nearly all
parents who commit federal crimes get
off scot-free
right gabriel malar has an entire column
on this where he went through the senate
democrat co-sponsored bill written
carelessly it doesn't distinguish
between migrant children at the border
and US citizen children already within
the united states the bill further does
not distinguish between federal officers
handling the border crisis and federal
law enforcement pursuing the ordinary
course of their duties the bill provides
that an agent or officer of a designated
agency shall be prohibited from removing
a child from his or her parents or legal
guardian at or near the port of entry or
within 100 miles of the border of the
United States okay well there this is a
serious problem because if you can't
remove the kids from the parents then
you can't arrest the parents according
to the 9th Circuit Court of Appeals so
their bill actually just releases all
illegal immigrants who come across the
board with kids but of course that's
their entire policy now here's the
hilarious part jeh Johnson who you'll
recall was the Secretary of Homeland
Security under Barack Obama the
execrable
DHS secretary under brocco bomb from
2013 to 2017 who presided over this
Obama era policy you know the Obama era
policy of keeping kids together with
parents and detention centers he has an
entire piece in The Washington Post
virtually signaling so he did the exact
same thing Trump is now saying that he's
gonna do and he's a long piece in The
Washington Post talking about what a
good dude he is just like luis gutierrez
says he has a soul he has a heart and
it's really nice calves anyway here's
what he says my wife and I spent
Mother's Day in 2014 at a u.s. Border
Patrol Center in McAllen Texas the
facility had been built for single
adults but it looked like a crude
daycare center flooded with children
in the midst of that flood my eyes were
drawn to one little girl sitting alone
at a desk and being processed by a
Border Patrol agent I was struck by her
long black hair which was beautiful
despite the hot and dirty journey from
Central America she had just completed I
asked her why did you come here she
replied I'm looking for my mother in the
United States she began to try cry the
translator began to cry I began to cry
yeah really there's what he's writing
okay this is the guy who's responsible
for actual families being held in
detention centers in 2014-2015 and who
said openly that this is a deterrent
policy designed to keep little girls
with beautiful black hair from
journeying from Central America he says
as I witnessed the Trump
administration's current practice of
separating children from their parents
at the border with Mexico the image of
that little girl and hundreds of other
migrant women and children is fixed in
my mind not the not the images of those
kids who you are keeping in detention
centers
you know jeh Johnson the images of
course that have to do with Trump now
here's the whole point here Democrats
don't actually have to act
sympathetically all they have to do is
is act as though they are sympathetic
they don't actually have to pursue
policies that are sympathetic to
American citizens they don't have to
pursue good legal policies all they have
to do is talk about how much they cry
and we're all supposed to pretend that
means that they have the best of
intentions he says I hesitate to
criticize my successors in office who
are burdened with the responsibility of
keeping the u.s. homeland and its border
secure
I hesitate to cast doubt on the hard
work of those who once worked for me in
the DHS yeah he hesitates in the pages
of the Washington Post but when it comes
to certain offensive and wrongheaded
government policies those of us with a
public voice and who understand the
issue cannot stay silent so what exactly
is a problem with a policy according to
Jay Johnson he says he doesn't like the
zero-tolerance deterrence policy he
doesn't like that everybody who's coming
across the border illegally is arrested
now he doesn't have anything to say
about the actual separation policy
because he engaged in it it doesn't
actually have anything to say about
keeping families together because he
engaged in it instead he just says that
we should get rid of the zero-tolerance
policy which essentially means that we
should release all of these people into
the center of the United States he says
the answer to the underlying problem is
twofold first send more aid to Central
America in 2016 Congress started down
this road by appropriating 750 million
bucks and assistance from Guatemala
Honduras and El Salvador in subsequent
years that level of support has fallen
off so we're supposed to pay off these
countries second encouraged the
neighboring countries in the region
Mexico Panama Costa Rica Belize to
develop their own systems for accepting
Central
and refugees and asylum-seekers okay
this is the hilarious part so his two
solutions
don't involve separation or keeping kids
together with their parents the only
solutions he's actually suggesting jeh
Johnson the former DHS secretary under
kind caring generous Barack Obama is cut
a check to Honduras and try to ask the
Mexicans to take care of the problem
those were really his only two solutions
that's it nothing about parental
separation nothing about keeping kids
together with their parents all of which
suggests this is just politically driven
crap it's just politically driven
nonsense which of course it is I mean
that's that's all this is it's just
deliver deliberately stupid it's it's
it's so irritating to watch as the media
falls prey to this and they're doing it
on purpose I'm gonna give you the worst
of all of these people's responses in
just one second but for that you're
gonna have to go over to Daley wire calm
for $9.99 a month you can subscribe to
daily wire when you do you get the rest
of this show live get the rest of the
Andrew Klavan show live we get the rest
of the crapping Michael Mol's show live
if that's something that you deeply
deeply need and when you get in that
$9.99 a month subscription you also get
to ask us questions on Fridays when we
do the conversation earlier this week we
had the angry step started the
conversation ever with Alicia Krauss and
the questions came fast and furious
because I was furious so it was great
if you want to ask questions and have
those questions answered become a
subscriber also you get first crack at
our VIP tickets going to our big events
like we're doing in Dallas and Phoenix
coming up in August if you get the
annual subscription for 99 dollars here
you get this behold the glory the
leftist year's hot or cold tumbler
reappeared from the ether today it is
just the best tumbler that you will ever
experience and you will enjoy it
immensely if you just want to listen
later go over to iTunes go over to
youtube go to SoundCloud wherever you
listen subscribe leave us a review we
have a big Sunday special coming up this
week with Jason Whitlock the the Fox
Sports 1 anchor we talked about the NFL
we talked about the NBA we talked about
the intersection of culture and politics
it was great and you're gonna wanna
listen to it so check that out we are
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
already said the stupidest of all
possible responses to this this whole
border scenario which feels ginned up
it's not to say that there's not a
problem with the policy there is a
problem with the policy there has been a
problem with the policy there will
continue to be a problem with the policy
until Congress does something about it
Congress is not going to do anything
about it because Democrats are far more
interested in yelling and screaming and
doing stompy foot than they aren't
actually solving things the proof of
this comes courtesy of Joe Kennedy the
third so nothing I like better than a
guy who's only famous because he had a
grandpa who was president that's that
that's my favorite thing as you know I'm
a big into the nepotism I just I love it
and Joe Kennedy the third a man who
dumped his face into a vat of chapstick
before speaking in his response to the
State of the Union address is now
tweeting we're supposed to take him
seriously because his grandpa was
President of the United States and also
banged around a lot here's a
representative Joe Kennedy the 37 you
might not know this about me but I'm a
white guy now he knew dude he says as a
white guy
I would encourage Donald Trump and his
fellow GOP white guys to consult a not
white guy in their efforts to enact
comprehensive immigration reform in less
than 24 hours oh my god it's worth
noting here that 50% of all I NS agents
50% of all ice agents are Hispanic are
non-white so it might might be worth
noting that so if you consult the people
over at ice my guess is that they have
some ideas but they might not actually
agree with Joe Kennedy I love the
assumption that all black people in
brown people agree with Joe Kennedy on
his preferred policy of releasing all
illegal immigrants into the United
States on mass it's really just because
of a whiteness it's just because of
toxic whiteness I'm surprised I'm gone
with that yet we've got we've got white
supremacy we've got white we have white
power we have all these terms of art I'm
surprised I'm gonna toxic whiteness
right our whiteness is making us toxic
yeah I love that Joe Kennedy a white man
is lecturing other people on all this
stuff you know I'm less white than Joe
Kennedy presumably because it depends
I'm Jewish so I guess that Jewish is
less white maybe hmm
it depends okay so he then he tweeted
out might be my cautious side but it
seems like there could be unforeseen
consequences like entire families being
indefinitely locked in cages just my two
cents
again the Democrats are unified in their
approach here they're going to bash from
for separating families and then they're
going to bash them for bringing families
back together they don't want anyone
arrested they want everyone released
into the interior of the United States
this is their end goal it's really it's
astonishing that they're this clear
about and that the media
seem not to care at all but you know
shocker that's that's what the media do
now meanwhile this is this is an amazing
amazing story about the ACLU it turns
out that the ACLU is now about to change
its policies for a long time the ACLU
was a free speech organization right
they're the kind of people who would
defend Nazis marching in Skokie where
they famously defended a Nazi march in
Skokie because the idea was that they
they had to they it was deeply important
that they defend the free speech rights
of people whom they disagree and for
that I give the ACLU credit well now
there's an internal memo from the
American Civil Liberties Union and they
say that they're going to weigh their
interest in protecting the First
Amendment against other commitments to
social justice racial equality and
women's rights given the possibility of
the defensive speech might undermine
ACLU goals in other words the ACLU which
was supposed to be the premier of civil
liberties union in the United States is
now changing its policy they're going to
balance free speech concerns like you
should be able to say what you want in
the United States of America like the
First Amendment they're going to balance
that with does it offend black people
that's really what this is well does it
does it offend LGBT people so in other
words if for example the state of
California cracks down on this show
because that broadcast from the state of
California and I say that a man is a man
and a woman is a woman and you can't
magically change from one to the other
if the state of California were to crack
down on me and attempt to find me and I
went to the ACLU and I said listen guys
you may disagree with me but this is a
basic First Amendment issue the ACLU
you would have 20 years ago defended me
now the ACLU says listen we may agree
with you on First Amendment grounds but
that's really offensive to transgender
people so we're not going to defend you
anymore so here is the confidential memo
obtained by a former board member it's
amazing they say our defensive speech
may have a greater or lesser harmful
impact on the equality and justice work
to which we are also committed so
they're now going to do a balancing act
and they're now going to do a balancing
act
they say the ACLU is a premier defender
of the Bill of Rights and works on
multiple civil liberties and civil
rights issues using an integrated
advocacy approach that includes
litigation communications grassroots
activism and policy advocacy our
position in one area can sometimes
present a conflict with our work and
goals in another area well no it
shouldn't because you're talking about
government policy right when you're
talking about government policy you're
dislike of a particular Nazi statement
does not mean that you think that the
government should be able to ban that
Nazi statement two things can be true
ones I hate Nazis I also think Nazis
have rights
in the United States of America hey
bottom line free speech applies to
people with whom I disagree and then
their internal memo says work to protect
free speech may raise tensions with
racial justice reproductive freedom or a
myriad of other rights where the
contents of the speech we seek to
protect conflicts with our policies on
those matters and/or otherwise is
directed at menacing vulnerable groups
for individuals at the same time work to
advance equality may create tensions
with speech and religious liberty
privacy safeguards may create tensions
with protections for women in the
domestic sphere as a multi-issue
organization these conflicts are
inevitable we cannot eliminate them but
we can ensure that we consider them
carefully and thoroughly why is this
coming up
they say the ACLU is involvement in the
protests and subsequent tragedy in
Charlottesville Virginia in August 2017
brought these issues to the fore once
again and prompted these guidelines
first proposed on the nationwide called
the ACL u--'s affiliate legal directors
these guidelines are designed to assist
in consideration of the competing
interests that may arise when such
conflicts arise in other words they
defended the right of the
Charlottesville protesters who were
white supremacists to to do the rally
and then they didn't like what emerge
and now they don't want to defend those
rights anymore hey this is the death of
the First Amendment this is the end of
the First Amendment so this is a full
this is a full surrender to the forces
of intersectionality so in The Wall
Street Journal this former board member
talks about this entire situation the
former board member who revealed this
memo was a person named Wendy kam and
I'm gonna go through her op-ed in the
Wall Street Journal in just saying so
here's what she says what she says is
the furthest speech case guidelines
reflected to motion of free speech in
the ACLU hierarchy of values they're
vague references to the serious harm to
marginalize people occasion by speech
can easily include the presumed
psychological effects of racist or
otherwise hateful hateful speech which
is constitutionally protected but
contrary to ACLU values faced with
perceived conflicts between freedom of
speech and progress toward equality the
ACLU is likely to choose equality if the
Supreme Court adopted the ACL u--'s
balancing test it would greatly expand
government power to restrict restrict
speech and this is exactly right of
course this is why there are a lot of
folks on the right deeply
concerned that all of the hate speech
legislation that you see in Canada is
going to come to the United States
forthwith
that very soon what you're going to see
is legislation pursued by Democrats and
upheld by courts that says that you
cannot say things that offend other
people and if you offend other people
then you will be
fully responsible in a court of law for
offending other people the end of the
First Amendment is at hand and what we
are watching right now is deeply scary
and deeply troubling and the fact the
ACLU is caving to it is demonstrative of
the collapse of liberalism into leftism
I've always said there's a difference
between people who are liberal and
people who are of the left people who
are liberal are people who may disagree
with me on policies like the amount of
government involvement in the economy
but they believe I have a right to speak
they believe that I have a right to live
my life as I see fit for the most part
with certain government regulations that
would restrict interactions between
people in the business sphere right or
they believed in redistribute of
economics but they believe that I should
be able to talk as I see fit leftist by
contrast believe that my very speech is
a threat to their safety it's a it's a
it's a destruction of the it's a it's a
a bolstering of institutions of
privilege and therefore my speech has to
be shut down
well leftists are the people who are
protesting me on campus leftists are the
ones who are protesting me liberals are
the ones were debating me leftists are
the ones who are protesting me and
asking that I be shut down on campus
these leftists used to be at odds with
the ACLU the ACLU used to say people on
the Left we're trying to shut down free
speech these are part of the problem
these are the bad guys but instead
they've decided that they are going to
collapse a full scale into the
foolishness of the of the hard left and
now they are going to give up on free
speech entirely and instead they're
going to just jump full-scale into a
into an embrace of intersectional
politics in which race and gender matter
a lot more than basic principles like
freedom of speech now with all that said
you wonder why Trump is drawing big
numbers of rallies it's because of stuff
like this there's because the ACLU is
because media malfeasance
so Trump yesterday was in northern
Minnesota Minnesota went very narrowly
for Hillary Clinton in the last election
cycle she only won it by I think it was
under two percent and so Trump actually
has some momentum in Minnesota and he is
not wrong when he says the Democrats are
putting illegal immigrants before
American citizens he I can't say that
he's wrong when he says this when
Democrats are openly saying that all
illegal immigrants who cross the border
with kids should be released into the
center of the country
Emma Kratz put illegal immigrants before
they put American citizens what the hell
is going on
okay so I can't argue with him I'd like
to say that he's wrong
but I'm having a problem saying that
he's wrong when I went again Democrats
were making very clear that this is how
they feel about this stuff and by the
way the media malfeasance continues
full-scale here's President Trump
yesterday saying that he wanted to send
ms-13 back he said that it was we it was
necessary to send ms-13 back and ABC
News said that he said all illegal
immigrants including children we have
ms-13 gangs we have taken them out of
our country by the thousands they're not
sending their finest that I can tell you
and we're sending him to hell back he's
specifically talking about ms-13 ABC
News headlined that he was talking about
all illegal immigrants I love it I love
it it's just it's just spectacular so
this is you wonder why President Trump
continues to gain momentum it's because
the left cannot just make factual
critiques of President Trump they gin up
false narratives and use them against
him and then they use those false
narratives in order to push liberal
organizations like the ACLU into hard
left ISM by saying the priority here has
to be fighting the bad guy and the bad
guy is the hit Larry and Trump and if we
can fight Trump if we can fight the hit
Larry and right by violating First
Amendment principles by violating the
Constitution well then we will have made
the world a much much better place the
left's
the left's drive for utopia means that
they're going to run roughshod over your
rights and this is driving people to
worry in a reactionary support of anyone
who promises to be anti left that's
what's happening in the country right
now and that's a dangerous phenomena
because now we have reactionary politics
on both sides and very little principle
the opposition to specific violations of
Liberty okay time for some things I like
and then some things that I hate so
things I like well I think we need some
real acting music after all this because
we never frustrating day so Dvorak spano
quintet number two so Dvorak as a Czech
composer and he lived about the time of
Brahms Brahms was a big fan of Dvorak
you you if you know Dvorak music it's
because you have heard his music from
the New World Symphony the New World
Symphony was written when he traveled
through the United States is his ninth
symphony I believe I and the new world
is is used very frequently in film
particularly the second movement of the
New World Symphony which is used in
clear and present danger they use it at
military funerals sometimes but the but
this is his
piano quintet I'm very into the piano
quintet as a form so there there are
lots of different forms of chamber music
a piano quintet is is quite wonderful
because instead of a full booming sound
of the orchestra kennel quintet is two
violins violas cellist and pianist and
so you get a wide variety of sound in
sort of the minimal number of people
here's the beginning of foreshocks
quintet in a major opus 81
[Music]
okay I think we've relaxed enough so
that's that's good stuff from from
Dvorak go check that out this is also
great writing music okay it's great
writing and great studying music chamber
music is great for that and it's a hell
of a lot better than eight bleep okay I
mean like that that terrible new Beyonce
song first of all kudos to the multiple
people who have now taken my lyric read
of eight bleep and put it on YouTube to
the actual soundtrack from eight poop by
Beyonce and jay-z kudos to you you have
made great art apparently my version
first of all you've never heard me
Spitfire is that how we say it
Spitfire okay we've never heard any
Spitfire but if I chose to do so let me
tell you I would wrap like cardi B okay
maybe whose cardi B I don't know anyway
okay time for a thing I hate okay so
this is a great piece from Jessie
Daniels and opinion columnist for The
Huffington Post so you know this is
gonna be awesome right it's from The
Huffington Post alright so you just know
it's gonna be great here is the piece
the piece is titled why the face of
family separation is a white woman Wow
the face of family separation is a white
woman again it's race that drives family
separation because you see white people
are the worst they're just the worst
who's writing this why a white lady
indeed but here's what she writes when
President Donald Trump referred to some
immigrants as animals homeland security
secretary Christian Nielsen was quick to
defend him if anyone wants to quibble
about whether or not we should call
those people animals perhaps the quibble
should be whether we call them something
worse well again he was talking about
ms-13 people whose literal slogan is
what does it shoot rape kill is some
something like that it's insane and now
Nielsen is leaning into enforcing the
zero-tolerance policy of separating
children from their families at the
border that's not the zero tolerance
policy the zero tolerance policy is
arresting everyone crosses the border
the separation is a necessary legal
byproduct of the arrest a family
separation has been portrayed as a
women's issue in the media with all four
former first living first ladies
opposing it the administration has
deployed Nielson along with White House
press secretary Sarah Huckabee Sanders
too defended both women appeared in a
press briefing on Monday and performed
that job
gussto white women like Nilsson and
Sanders have always been part of making
white supremacy seem more palatable
unless like the brutal repressive
ideology it is historical examples
abound from white women who worked
alongside male colonizers to the wives
of slaveholders who punished the people
their husbands owned to the white women
who packed the picnic lunches for and
took the photos of the lynching
purportedly committed in their defense
white women have played active roles in
advancing and protecting white supremacy
and then she says their counterparts
today are women like Laura Ingraham Ann
Coulter right Laura Norman Ann Coulter
are both women who I'm sure would have
involved themselves in lynching of black
people for no reason and taking pictures
of it I just I love the idea that race
and sex defined the evil and the woman
who's writing is of that race and sex
but this is the the point of
intersectionality intersectionality is
the suggestion that we can define you
purely by the various groups to which
you belong unless you do penance unless
you come forward and achieve the grace
of the left by claiming that you have
moved beyond your own parochial
interests as a white woman writing for
the Huffington Post
now you have given up all of your own
opinions and you have embraced the
collective because you no longer an
individual obviously you've moved beyond
your whiteness and your womanís and
instead you are going to say exactly
what the left wants you to say and this
sort of silliness obviously leads the
country become a much worse place
Bridget Christian Nielsen and and Sarah
Huckabee Sanders are not doing what
they're doing because they're white
women they're doing what they are doing
because they are conservatives and work
for the Trump administration and that is
why they're doing what they're doing
end of story but I guess if we're gonna
reduce everybody down to racial
categories you can't be particularly
surprised when the country tears itself
apart okay we will be back here tomorrow
with all the latest plus the mailbag cuz
tomorrow's a Friday Wow we've made it to
the end of the week almost we're almost
there guys
see you here then I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018